it's the equivalent of lockdown for
anything with feathers keepers of birds
across England have now just seven days
to house their animals the rules the
same for large free-range flocks and
hobbyist hen Keepers alike
this is the worst birdflower epidemic
we've ever seen with 80 cases of the
highly pathogenic virus in England alone
since the start of the month
a compulsory housing order was already
in place for East Anglia with the
highest number of cases with new
outbreaks continuing from next Monday
the housing order will be extended to
cover the rest of England this is truly
is an unprecedented situation we have
had a number of outbreaks of even
influenza not just in the UK but in
Europe and globally as well but Farmers
you know they they are under pressure to
keep their their Birds happy and healthy
but they are doing all they can to make
sure that that they are
here at the perbrite institute in Surrey
scientists are analyzing every new
sample of the h5n1 virus that's causing
the outbreak it first emerged in farm
birds in China in 1996.
the conclusion with just a few genetic
mutations it's evolved from a disease of
poultry into one which infects wild
birds which then reinfect farmed flocks
allowing it for the first time to
persist between outbreaks the migratory
bird before that come and go but now in
the summer the virus remain in the UK
and persisting and therefore this virus
is more dangerous in that term for the
poultry compared to the previous viruses
is it fair to say we're looking at a
different virus a different h5n1 than we
were before
that's right so those viruses were
different than this one
given how rapidly bird flu is changing
in order to stay on top of the current
outbreak and have any hope of preventing
future ones the scientists here are
having to work constantly to understand
the evolution of the virus
bird flu vaccine like the one they're
developing here could break the cycle of
infection between farmed and wild birds
but trade rules currently prohibit their
use this epidemic May force a rethink
Tom Clark Sky News